un géant de bronze décapité le
traitement réservé à ce monument est le
symbole de décennies de controverse au
pays en ou 2018 cette autre statue de
john et milk board érigée devant l'hôtel
de ville de victoria en
colombie-britannique et retiré dans un
effort de réconciliation avec les
peuples autochtones
le tout premier premier ministre du
canada artisans de la politique
d'assimilation a fait adopter la loi sur
les indiens
il a également instauré le système des
pensionnats autochtones
la même année la statue d'edward
cornwallis fondateur d'halifax et
déboulonné elle aussi cet officier
britannique offrait des primes à
quiconque tu es un micmac homme femme ou
enfant et lui rapporter son scalp des
manifestants réclamaient son départ
depuis des années c'est quelque chose
que j'ai le souvenir de mais je pense
pas que c'est nécessaire d'avoir ici en
2017 cette remise en question autour du
devoir de mémoire se retrouve au coeur
de la journée nationale des autochtones
cette année là le premier ministre
trudeau annonce que son bureau sur la
colline parlementaire sera rebaptisé and
was once longerait voir les architectes
des pensionnats autochtones
hector langevin ancien ministre des
affaires indiennes et des travaux
publics
et comme mcdonald's l'un des pères de la
confédération et on souhaitait vraiment
faire un geste fort en renommant à cette
rue a tâté ken bravo tout le monde et
puis à montréal encore une fois après
des années de controverse là aussi en
2019 la rue amherst et rebaptisé le
général britannique a mené une guerre
bactériologique aux autochtones
jeffrey amherst leur a offert des
couvertures infestée par la variole le
panneau qui portait son nom affiche
maintenant le mot à tâter guen qui
signifie fraternité le nom est ma
appropriée à taux teg voulant du tout
tout notre relation on parle pas de
justes canadien québécois on parle de
l'humanité c'est la famille humaine et
de l'humanité force est de constater que
certains symboles plutôt que d'incarner
la fraternité sont devenus souffre de
divisions ici sébastien desrosiers radio
canada morin
[Applaudissements]